now there is a super simple very quick
test that you can do
to figure out if you have bowel disease
or gut issues okay which i'm going to
explain at the end you can fast forward
if you want but i recommend that you
just hear me out because i have some
very important points related to
your gut whether you have celiac crohn's
ulcerative colitis diverticulitis
small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth when we're talking about
bowel disease
it usually relates to your microbes okay
you have trillions of microbes in your
gut and there could be some alteration
in the amounts or the type of microbes
you might have too little good bacteria
and too much bad bacteria
and so of course people will say well
you need to feed your bacteria fiber and
this is why they recommend
11 servings of grains right with at
least three of those 11 servings being
whole grains because of course we all
know
that fiber feeds the microbes right we
want healthy fiber but the confusing
part about that is pull grains doesn't
usually have much fiber like seven
percent fiber it's not that much it has
a lot of other things like starch but
it's not like a very high
fiber
food
it also has phytic acid in it which if
you don't know what that is that blocks
minerals okay specifically iron
zinc
calcium magnesium
it tightly binds minerals so if anyone
were to tell you that well grains are
nutrient dense
just bring up this point about phytic
acid that blocks the nutrition
in whole grains but in refined grains
there is not hardly any nutrition
because they're refining it that's why
they have to fortify or enrich the
grains with some a couple synthetic
vitamins and then they can call it a
nutrient-dense foods because you're
adding a couple synthetic vitamins and
then we have the protein in grains which
is gluten which literally tears up
the digestive tract and creates so many
problems so even though you may not have
a gluten allergy it could be a gluten
sensitivity so that's a real big factor
so honestly i think the worst thing you
could possibly eat for digestive
problems
is grains now when we talk about fiber
in general um people associate you have
to eat enough fiber to prevent
constipation because we all know for a
fact that constipation is just a lack of
fiber and if you just take more fiber
then you can actually go on a regular
basis now there's a lot of different
types of fiber out there you have the
fiber from the grain you have fiber from
salad right
that's a good amount of fiber plus the
salad has no gluten there's very little
amounts of phytic acid except maybe in
certain things like spinach that has
oxalates and phytic acid it also has a
lot of nutrients potassium magnesium
folic acid vitamin c
so of course salad would be a much
better fiber than grains and then you
have all these new functional fibers
they're talking about in all the keto
treats like the soluble corn fiber and
the tapioca fiber and the inulin and the
chicory root okay with so many people
having digestive bloating and gas from
these products it's just off the chart
so what is happening in the colonies
creating all this bloating and gas well
you're getting this fermentation okay
these microbes are attempting to break
down some of these fibers and they're
releasing a lot of methane gas and other
gases and
all sorts of things that are creating
distension
and pain in your
colon
now relating to microbes
there's three types of general
categories of microbes you have microbes
that are harmful okay to you those are
called pathogens
you also have microbes that help you
okay like friendly bacteria those are
called mutualists they have a mutual
relationship with you they give you
certain benefits and you give them
certain benefits you give them a place
to live right so there's this nice
exchange then you have microbes that are
kind of neutral
they're called commensal
they live in your body they don't harm
you they don't help you they don't
bother you
so
here's what you need to know about that
a good amount of the microbes that you
have in your gut actually can change
morph into
the bad guys so in other words you can
have a microbe that is neutral that can
turn pathogenic because if you think
about it where do these bad microbes
come from right do they just kind of
appear from nowhere no they're actually
coming from
a condition from being neutral to now
being pathogenic or harmful and that
definitely applies to like e coli
and h pylori
and c diff
and even candida when the environment of
your gut changes
these microbes shift their state of
beingness their condition and they can
start creating trouble for you so when
the environment changes like there's
stress in your gut
one stress would be antibiotics right
now you say well i don't take
antibiotics
did you realize that wheat that grain
that you took
was sprayed with glyphosate which is an
herbicide and
classified as an antibiotic
in fact the company that created this
product
also got a patent
with a different application so
glyphosate is an antibiotic it kills
microbes in the soil and it kills
microbes in your gut so we can add
another one to this list with the phytic
acid the gluten and now that's
considered an antibiotic which is really
bizarre to me that
they are recommending the majority of
your calories should be
grains
the actual thing that would create
so many problems for your gut i mean
it's just it's mind-blowing and of
course there's other things that throw
off the environment you have drugs you
have junk food alcohol artificial
sweeteners that's another one that can
disrupt your gut
i think and i predict down the road we
will see
these functional fibers like the corn
fibers and the tapioca fibers being
something that alters the environment
for the microbes to turn them from good
to bad
and so when we're dealing with these gut
issues we do need to recognize and
understand that these microbes are very
very important they're the most
successful in survival they've adapted
to the harshest conditions they can live
at the bottom of the ocean they can live
in the clouds they can live in lava
i mean it's just incredible how they've
adapted they're the most numerous
they're the most diversified and we
depend on them and without them we would
not even be alive they're a big part of
our immune system they help make
vitamins they help us with digestion and
they give a secondary kind of compounds
that are beneficial to our health now
let's get to
the important way to determine
if
you
have gut issues okay here we go
step one
eliminate all fiber from your diet for
three days
okay that's step one
see how you feel step two add the fiber
back into the diet for three days
now compare how you felt when you
eliminated the fiber
versus when you added the fiber and then
you really know for sure
if you have gut issues it could be
inflammation it could be some other type
of dysbiosis going on with your gut but
that's a really simple way
without having to go through a bunch of
testing without having to wait for some
scientific study without having them to
put you under and having a scope go into
your intestine simply eliminate your
fiber and see if you feel better then
you know for sure something is going in
your gut and that's the diet that you
that's going to work best for you right
now
if you add the fiber and you feel better
chances are you don't have a gut issue
and you just now fed the microbes and
now they're happy because they have some
food of course the fiber i'm
recommending
is from vegetable fiber like salads but
here's the question
if you eliminate fiber
isn't that the only food for microbes
aren't your microbes going to die off
because they have no more food
well like i said before microbes can
adapt to almost any condition they can
eat almost any food did you realize that
microbes can even live on
metal
plastics
and even your waste
so even in a condition called sibo
you have these friendly bacteria in your
small intestine and what are they eating
well they're eating the fiber but
they're also eating other nutrients
they're eating other things they're
eating protein so if your body does not
do well on fiber then don't consume
fiber and i know in my books and things
i recommend seven to ten cups of salad
per day but some people can't do that
personally when i do that i feel better
but i know a lot of people that don't
feel good when they consume that much
fiber even if it's salad
not even talking about grains in fact i
was puzzled back then when my when i
consumed more meat okay and not any more
grains of course at that time i wasn't
consuming any salad
my bowels actually did very good and i
was very confused at that at the time
but over the years i've healed my gut
and i can tolerate more
vegetable fiber and the main reason i
personally consume vegetables is not
necessarily just for the fiber
it's for the nutrients it's for the
potassium magnesium vitamin c
folate things like that just as one last
side note related to this topic
when you consume fermented food like
sauerkraut or kimchi
that is way better than fiber so
let's say for example you get off fiber
for a period of time and you want to
introduce fiber back into the diet i
would recommend introducing fermented
fiber as in sauerkraut kimchi things
like that now since we're on the topic
of microbes okay another really good
video for you to watch would be the one
on
how microbes are affected when you fast
check it out i put it up right here